c'est le gr10 on vient de mourir ce
matin quelle est votre réaction
je suis effondrée ces vêtements vous la
prenez jamais parié des malades d'un
grand volume pour vous immense parce que
l'avion est mort oh non c'est pas
possible
marcel gravillons c'est pas vrai
monsieur on apprend à l'instant la mort
de marcel gravillons quelle est votre
réaction
mars grémillon nom marcel gravillons je
connais pas philosophe footballeurs qui
jouent aux échecs honte de vous dire que
je ne connais pas un point c'est tout
bon c'est pas grave on fait comme si
vous connaissiez on a besoin de réaction
vous me dites oh la la quel dommage quel
grand bonhomme l'on peut dire c'est un
grand boum si je le connais pas jean
belin parce que tout le monde doit son
avis est un philosophe footballeurs qui
jouent aux échecs donc il est assez
complet quand même ok complet pour être
complet cgt complet messieurs nous
apprenons à l'instant la disparition de
martial gravillons quelle est votre
réaction
écoutez si c'est une personne connue
doux et tout ça que cela vous affecte je
participe à votre votre peine et vous
personnellement c'est quelqu'un qui vous
a marqué non mais si puisque je vous dis
de dire oui monsieur je ne dirais pas
oui parce que je suis têtu je suis pas
breton mais je suis têtu et oui mais
vous allez oui quand je veux dire oui
mais vous gifle et vous aurez gagné quoi
monsieur nous on a besoin de faire un
sujet dont malgré mes 70 balais je vais
pas me laisser giflé comme ça un bon
alors on va on va se calmer on va la
faire
monsieur quelle est votre réaction ma
réaction allait elle est tout à fait
neutre maïs collet l'a perçue très
peinés je ne veux pas dire je suis très
peiné si monsieur ses objectifs c'est
l'information
moi ça ça m'intéresse voilà c'est bien
mais allez allez vous laisse à votre
votre émotion monsieur ces personnes
tristes une de plus qui ne veut pas
témoigner encore sous le choc des
gravillons vient de mourir
qui ça l'inventeur de l'abat jour madame
vous avez une réaction
vous avez un traitement donc nous avons
enfin trouvé un témoignage d'une jeune
femme qui admirait marcel gravillons
cette crapule qui a dénoncé
rappelons le de 1800 résistant en 43 un
homme que personne ne regrettera ce
qu'on appelle en termes de métiers une
heure dire merci mademoiselle vous
m'avez pas dit que c'est un collabo moi
je vous ai dit de d'emblée que je
connais je ne savais pas qui c'était
donc je suis désolé vous êtes foutu de
moi encore je veux dire chacun ses goûts
chacun ses goûts je connais pas le type
vous m'avez fait vous m'avez dit de dire
oui oui c'est la formation fait toujours
comme ça non comment ça on le journal je
peux pas te fait pas déjà juger
quelqu'un je connais pas vous l'avez
fait vous l'admirer pas c'est vous qui
va qui m'avait dit de répondre oui moi
jamais je capte témoins et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou